what's up everybody it's your boy Zack
Evans I'm here at BuzzFeed and I'm gonna
make my co-workers rap battle again hard
juice mr. Ned former in the house
Ashley Prez is calling you out to rap
out I don't know if I can rap battle
Ashley well you're gonna have to yeah
can I pee first you can oh my god I
should get my hoodie on like Eminem
would do this is how it's gonna go you
get ten points for flow you get negative
1 points for every time you cuss there's
been a lot of rap beef lately we're
gonna change that today this is all
about complimenting each other so one
point for a compliment about just like
their physical features one point for
compliment about their character and one
point for describing why they're a good
friend I was I'm not gonna lie I was
writing like messed up raps about Ned
before I knew this is gonna happen and
now I got to switch it around here we go
Ashley hey girl I like your hair girl
and don't be snake me for blindness cuz
I think you have a lot of kindness you
are such a good friend to me you watch
out and let me go peepee this spells
over
get a life my name is Ned and I love my
wife I love rapping about kindness it's
so much easier hey hey got a guy with me
and he's nice and he's kind he's sly you
see his name is NaN he's got a wifey net
in the house getting high fee dang at
you really nice I like a hair your face
to style your swag Oh Ned what you got
in that bag it's your laptop you're so
organized
Sam never Tim
his favorite colors red Ned
his favorite colors red now you need to
thug it out for the rest of the day
deuces yo my boy Ryan B you ready to do
this yeah let's do it man
all right who you gettin who you gettin
let me get J tan you ready to rap battle
your candy that's gonna send that chair
all day oh yeah this is my beat right
here huh
check it out this is Ryan B he's a
decent emcee kind of like me he's all
like physically fit after doing three
months of that CrossFit and he can kind
of like rap a little bit yeah he's kind
of the yeah Justin looking good to day
Hey
look at your face like go away hair
looking fresh my god
I don't know what to do my dog just lost
the D Justin ten how do you feel
I'm not good Chris reinecker are you
ready to battle Quinta Brunson are you
ready to be my Mekhi Phifer
that's how ready I am I spread the
comments of the last rap battle and I
know that it was pretty unanimous that I
won and you were at close second based
on your life that's fine I will still
trash you hey hey Chris I like that
shirt and it makes me hurt because
you're my money and you're flowing and
you're making these videos every time I
see you I'm like eh Chris yo you're such
a good friend when I can be penned on
with your great hair and your great
stares and your brown eyes and that wide
smile I want to stay for a while and
spend some time with Chris Chris don't
this just
friends and I love you I wanna murder
joke your eyebrows on fleek your hair is
bitchin I love Quinta because inside she
listens and she tells you the truth and
she man I'd like to take photo booth and
stuff I forgot
I shouldn't cuss but I'm gonna do it you
like my cuss you like family
you're like a mother to me you're like a
brother to me I feels like I'm
stuttering but I continue I like this
shirt it's a BuzzFeed thing it was free
bizarre someone call 911 right now
because friendship fire friendship fire
y'all friendship fire tell me in the
comments who you think want this
compliment rap battle we'll see you next
time
deuces your mom gave birth to you in
which case she's great
your whole family is blessed to be in
the presence of you all the time do you
want to know what they say while Chris
is really good I hope he gives me a note
on my comical video so it can be better